DARLINGTON JOINS US RIGHT NOW
TO TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
ALL THINGS NFL BUT FIRST JEFF
WELCOME TO THE SHOW, AND I
THE SHOW AND I WANTED TO ASK
YOU THE MOUNTING ACCUSATIONS
THAT CONTINUE TO COME OUT.
YEAH. I MEAN EVERYBODY WHO
COVERS THE NFL LIKE THIS HAS
TO BE IN COMPLETE SHOCK THAT
SOMETHING LIKE THIS.
LANDED AT THE FEET OF DESHAUN
WATSON RIGHT NOW.
WELL, ABSOLUTELY. I MEAN, I
THINK THERE'S THE WORD THAT
YOU JUST USED IS PROBABLY
TWIST THE TWIST THAT THIS
THIS HAS SORT OF CREATED FOR
WHAT IS ALREADY THE BIGGEST
STORY LINE OF THE OFFSEASON
IS JUST SO UNFORTUNATE AND
THE THING WHEN I SAY
UNFORTUNATE IT'S UNFORTUNATE
IT IS UNFORTUNATE IF THIS IS
THESE ARE FABRICATED
ALLEGATIONS. THIS IS
UNFORTUNATE. OBVIOUSLY IF
THEY ARE NOT FABRICATED, I
MEAN THIS
IMPACTS DESHAUN WATSON FUTURE
AN ORGANIZATION'S FUTURE AND
LET US NOT FORGET. OF COURSE
THOSE WHO ARE ALLEGING
THESE CRIMES. SO I GUESS
THE WAY I LOOK AT THIS AS
YES, OBVIOUSLY, WE ARE
SHOCKED THAT THE SEAN
WATSON'S NAME IS BEING
MENTIONED WITH ALLEGATIONS
LIKE THESE BUT BUT AT THE
SAME TIME WE CAN'T LET THAT
SORT OF I GUESS COMPLETELY
YOU LOOK AT THIS THE WAY THAT
WE I GUESS MAINTAIN PATIENTS
ON BOTH SIDES AND AND SORT OF
SEE HOW THIS THING PLAYS OUT.
OUT JEFF DARLINGTON ESPN NFL
REPORTER HERE TALKING ABOUT
THE DESHAUN WATSON SITUATION
THE
NOW, I'M NOT A CONSPIRACY
THEORY THEORIST BUT A FEW
WEEKS AGO. I WAS JUST LIKE,
YOU KNOW, IS THERE A HAND IN
HERE FROM THE TEXANS IN TERMS
OF WHEN IT WAS A STORY THAT
CAME OUT ON INSTAGRAM AND
EVERYTHING LIKE THAT, BUT THE
MOUNTING ALLEGATIONS SEEM TO
BE LIKE IT'S A PREDATORY
PROCESS AND THE CANCEL
CULTURE THAT WE'RE LIVING IN
RIGHT NOW MAKES ME WANT TO
THINK THAT A NO ONE'S GOING
WITH THESE KIND OF THINGS
GOING ON AND WHETHER OR NOT
JUST ON WATSON ACTUALLY EVER.
PLACE ANOTHER DOWN IN THE NFL
BECAUSE OF IT. I UNDERSTAND
WE GOT TO LET THINGS PLAY OUT
IN THE COURTS, BUT I MEAN
WHERE WE SIT NOW IN OUR
CULTURE IN OUR COUNTRY.
THERE'S A GOOD CHANCE THAT WE
DON'T SEE DESHAUN WATSON
PLAYING FOOTBALL EVER OR FOR
A LONG AND EXTENDED PERIOD OF
TIME WELL, AND THAT'S WHERE I
THINK SO TWO THINGS. FIRST OF
ALL, I MEAN LOOK I'VE GOT
FROM YOU KNOW, WE CAN'T BE
NAIVE TO THIS. I GOT FRIENDS
WHO HAVE NO THE TIME ABOUT
STUFF THAT YOU KNOW ENTAILS
MY WORK LIFE OR THEIR LIFE.
HEY, DO YOU THINK THE TEXANS
YOU THINK THIS IS RIGHT TO
YOUR POINT? LIKE YOU THINK
THE TEXANS DID THIS LIKE I
CAN'T WRAP MY HEAD AROUND.
LIKE I ALWAYS LOOK FOR
MOTIVATION AND INCENTIVE. I
MEAN II GUESS WE COULD READ
HIS SPIT BALL ON IT. BUT LIKE
I JUST DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY A
TEAM THAT ULTIMATELY HAS TO
AT LEAST BE RECOGNIZING THAT
A TRADE IS THE MOST LIKELY
REGISTRATION IS IS THEY JUST
KILL EVERY BIT OF LEVERAGE
THAT THEY WOULD HAVE HAD. NO
THIS ISN'T RESOLVED FULLY A
WEEK BEFORE THE NFL DRAFT,
WHICH IS WHEN I TALK TO
ANTICIPATED TO ACTUALLY START
FIELDING CALLS FOR A TRADE.
I MEAN IF THIS ISN'T
RESOLVED BY THEN LIKE HOW DO
THEY MOVE FORWARD IT? JUST IT
IT CHANGES THE WHOLE
COMPLEXITY OF WHAT WAS
ALREADY SUCH A TOUCHY SUBJECT.
SO SO I DON'T BELIEVE THAT
IT DOES BENEFIT THEM TO HAVE
DONE THIS SO I DON'T I DON'T
SUBSCRIBE TO THAT NOTION BUT
TO THAT TO THAT SAME POINT
ABOUT THE TIMELINE, I JUST
LAID OUT.
LIKE DO I THINK THAT WE'LL
SEE DESHAUN WATSON PLAYED
FOOTBALL AGAIN? I HAVE NO IDEA
AND THE IDEA THAT WE'RE
HAVING THAT CONVERSATION
RIGHT NOW IN MARCH.
JUST MIND-BLOWING IT JUST IT
JUST LITERALLY TWIST MY HEAD
UP TO I DON'T I DON'T KNOW
WHAT HAPPENS NEXT. I DON'T
KNOW WHAT HAPPENS. NEXT. JEFF
JOINING US ESPN NFL REPORTER.
THAT'S KIND OF THE QUESTION.
I WANTED TO ASK LIKE WHAT?
NEXT THEY I FEEL YOU MAN. DO
THEY I MEAN THEY WENT AND GOT
TYROD TAYLOR FROM THE LOS
ANGELES CHARGERS WHO WAS WHO
WAS UP AND FOR LIKE 12
MILLION 12 AND A HALF MILLION
DOLLARS. SO IT'S A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF MONEY
IN ALL LIKELIHOOD. THEY EXPECT
TYROD TAYLOR TO AS OF RIGHT
NOW WHEN WE'RE GOING INTO
INTO MANY CAMPS AND THINGS
LIKE THAT. HE'S HE'S MOST
LIKELY GOING TO BE THE GUY
IAN IN THE DESHAUN WATSON
SCENARIO WELL, AND THAT'S
THAT'S THE THING THE FLUIDITY
OF THIS SITUATION. FIRST OF
ALL, I KIND OF DO THE TIE ROD
THING. I UNDERSTAND THAT THAT
FEELS LIKE A LOFTY PRICE FOR
A BACKUP IT I KIND OF VIEW IT
THE WAY I VIEWED ANDY DALTON
GOING TO THE COWBOYS LAST
YEAR, WHICH WAS NOT THAT HE
WAS GOING AS A LEVERAGE PLAY
FOR JERRY JONES AND THOSE
NEGOTIATIONS, BUT RATHER A
REALLY SOLID BACKUP WHO IS
HE?
UNEXPECTEDLY AVAILABLE ON A
ONE-YEAR DEAL WHERE IT DOES
PROVIDE YOU SECURITY BUT EVEN
IF IT'S NOT AN INSURANCE
POLICY, IT'S ALSO A GOOD
BACKUP IF THINGS WORK OUT. SO
THAT BEING SAID I STILL
I STILL LOOK AT THE THE
TIMELINE HERE. I MEAN IT
COULD ALL LIKE I LOOK AT THE
THE COMMENTS YESTERDAY FOR
THE STATEMENT THAT DASHON
WATSON'S ATTORNEY PUT OUT
YESTERDAY, AND I LOOK AT
GOT PROOF THAT ONE OF
THESE ALLEGATIONS IS IS A LIE.
SO MY THING IS YOU'VE GOT
THE ATTORNEY OF THOSE
ALLEGING THE CRIME AND YOU
HAVE THE ATTORNEY OF THE SHOW
WATSON BOTH SAYING THEY'VE
GOT THIS EVIDENCE. WELL, I
FEEL LIKE ON EITHER SIDE THIS
THING COULD EITHER FALL APART
OR GET EVEN EVEN STRONGER
LEGS BASED ON WHAT THAT
EVIDENCE EVIDENCE IS. I MEAN
YOU KNOW THE NEWS CYCLE COULD
LITERALLY JUST CHANGE TO
WHERE WOW DESHAUN WATSON
LITERALLY WAS WAS PART OF ONE
OF THE ONE OF THE MOST
HORRIBLE, YOU KNOW, JUST
RADON HER COVER-UPS. YEAH.
YEAH CHARACTER ASSASSINATIONS
WE'VE EVER SEEN THAT BEING
SAID LIKE THERE'S A LOT OF
ALLEGATIONS RIGHT NOW AGAIN
TOO MANY SO IT'S JUST OH MAN
LOOK. I JUST I DON'T KNOW
HOW WE GOT HERE, BUT I WILL
SAY LIKE, I THINK IT WAS LIKE
A WEEK AGO. I'M STARTING TO
LOOK AT THIS.
THING AND YOU CAN FEEL THAT
SNOWBALL EFFECT START TO
HAPPEN LIKE RIGHT OUT OF THE
GATES. EVERYBODY WAS LIKE, OH
THE SEAN WATSON IS NO WAY AND
I'M NOT SAYING WE'RE
CONCLUDING ANYTHING, BUT I
WAS STARTING TO LOOK AT IT
LIKE MAN. THIS IS NOT GOING
TO GO AWAY ANYTIME SOON. LIKE
THIS IS THIS IS HERE TO STAY
FOR THE OFFSEASON AND AND
AGAIN IT COMES BACK TO THE
SAME THING. I SAID RYAN, I
DON'T KNOW WHERE IT IS. I
HAVE NO IDEA WHAT HAPPENS
NEXT AND AT NO POINT. DO WE
WANT TO
CONCLUDE THAT THAT THESE
ALLEGATIONS AREN'T ABSOLUTELY
PROBLEMATIC AND IMPORT AWAY.
YEAH, THAT'S THAT'S IT.
THAT'S AN IMPORTANT THING TO
DO. THIS IS HORRIBLE YOUNGER
WAY, WHATEVER THE OUTCOME OF
THIS IT IS. IT IS HORRIBLE.
IT IS A HORRIBLE OUTCOME.
WHICHEVER WAY THIS THING GOES.
WELL, YOU KNOW WHEN THE OFF
SEASON STARTED I WANTED TO,
YOU KNOW DIVE INTO THE WILSON
WATSON WATCH EVERY SINGLE
DAY UNTIL THIS THING IS
RESOLVED, YOU KNOW, SO HOW IS
THE DISSIPATION OF THE WILSON
SIDE OF THIS RUSSELL?
WILSON HE'S MAKING SOME
ANNOUNCEMENTS NOW SAYS HE
WANTS ANTONIO BROWN IN IN
SEATTLE SOMETIME SOON IS THIS
IS MEAN THAT THE IDEA OF
RUSSELL WILSON BEING
SOMEWHERE ELSE NEXT YEAR IS
NOT SOMETHING THAT FANS
SHOULD BE LOOKING AT ANYMORE.
SO IF ANYTHING IT POINTSME
MORE TOWARD THE IDEA THAT YOU
WILL NOT BE ON THEIR OFFICER
IN 2021. I JUST I DON'T THIS
DOESN'T FEEL LIKE WHAT IT
FEELS TO PUBLIC AT THIS POINT
WHEN WE WE WENT YEARS IN THE
TOM BRADY BILL BELICHICK
RELATIONSHIP LIKE EVERY TIME
ANY SUGGESTION OF TENSION
CAME OUT. WE ALL BLASTED IT
OR MANY BLASTED IT AND
SUGGESTED NO WAY THEY'RE FINE
IT WASN'T ALWAYS FUN.
GOT THROUGH IT, BUT WHEN IT
STARTS TO GO PUBLIC YOU
REALIZE WOW, THE DEPTH OF
THIS IS MUCH. IT'S IT, YOU
KNOW THINK ABOUT LIKE JARED
GOFF AND SEANIX A LIKE A YEAR
AGO AT THIS TIME WHERE WE
REALLY THINKING LIKE THAT
THAT WAS ENDING IN IN SUCH A
FAST-PACED OF WORSE. SO WHEN
I TRANSLATE ALL THAT TO
RUSSELL WILSON, LIKE, I DON'T
KNOW MAN, I JUST IT STILL
DOESN'T FEEL LIKE WE'RE
HEADED TOWARD RUSSELL WILSON
WEEK ONE IN SEATTLE AND AND
THAT'S JUST KIND OF BASED ON.
YES.
YES WHAT I KNOW IN TERMS OF
WHERE THAT RELATIONSHIP IS
THAT IT DOESN'T FEEL LIKE
THERE'S SOME COOL BIOPIC
GOING ON WITH IT FIGURED IT
OUT. BUT THAT IS ALSO JUST A
LITTLE INSTINCTIVE SORT OF
PERSPECTIVE ON WHAT WE'VE
ALREADY EXPERIENCED WITH
OTHER QUARTERBACKS OUT THERE.
WOW, JEFF DARLINGTON ESPN NFL
REPORTED KIND OF YOU KIND OF
TOOK ME BACK THERE A LITTLE
BIT CAUSE I REALLY THOUGHT IT
WAS TRENDING IN THAT OTHER
DIRECTION THAT I MEAN,
THERE'S AN INCREDIBLE CAP HIT
THAT SEATTLE WOULD TAKE
GETTING RID OF THEM, BUT
THEY'RE WILLING TO TAKE THAT
ON TO REBUILD THEM.
LOOK, I MEAN IT GOT IT GOT IT
GOT CLOSE WITH THE BEARS.
WELL, I THINK WE ALL
RECOGNIZE LIKE
THAT GOT CLOSER THAN YEAH,
AND I REFUSE TO BELIEVE THAT
PETE CARROLL JUST SORT OF
BACKED OFF AND SAID, YOU KNOW
WHAT RUSS IS MY GUIDE. LIKE
WHEN HAVE WE HEARD ANYTHING
ABOUT RUSH RUSSELL WILSON AND
PETE CARROLL BASICALLY, YOU
KNOW COMING OUT AND SAYING
MAN, WE'RE IN THIS TOGETHER
WITH THIS IS YOU KNOW OUR
SO AGAIN, LIKE I I'M NOT
TRYING TO LIKE STIR IT UP OR
ANYTHING. I'M JUST INCLINED
TO SORT OF CONTINUE TO FOLLOW
THESE TWO.
IT'S GOT HER OUT THERE, WHICH
IS NOT SUGGESTING THAT I MEAN
IF LOOK WHAT HAPPENS IF
ANTONIA BROWN DOESN'T WIND UP
IN SEATTLE. LIKE II JUST I
THINK THERE'S SO MUCH TO PLAY
OUT BETWEEN NOW AND THE DRAFT
LET ALONE THE START OF THE
SEASON THAT I DON'T FEEL LIKE
THE RUSSELL WILSON SITUATION
HAS REACHED ANY SENSE OF
CONCLUSIVENESS. ALL RIGHT.
LET'S GET YOU OUT OF HERE
WITH A COUPLE BOOKKEEPING
STUFF WITH THE NFL JEFF
DARLINGTON ESPN AND A
FELL REPORTER HERE ON THE
RICH EYES AND SHOW I'M RYAN
LEAF FILLING IN FOR RICH THE
NFL DRAFT. OKAY WHEN THIS
CAME OUT AND WE WERE TOLD
THEY WERE GOING TO DO IT IN
CLEVELAND. YEAH WITH SOME
SORT OF FAN INTERACTION. WHAT
WAS YOUR THOUGHT PROCESS ON
THE US THAT AND I'VE BEEN AN
OUTSPOKEN PERSON AROUND
WHETHER OR NOT YOU KNOW
SPORTS SHOULD HAVE BEEN
PLAYED IN A WORLDWIDE
PANDEMIC, BUT I DON'T I DON'T
NECESSARILY KNOW IF THIS IS
THE BEST THING TO DO WHILE
WE'RE KIND OF COMING TO THE
END OF THIS.
SO AFTER WHAT WENT DOWN LAST
YEAR AND WHAT WE SAW IN TERMS
OF A BUNCH OF THOSE HIGH
DRAFTED PLAYERS AT HOME WITH
THEIR FAMILIES. I THINK WE
MIGHT SEE MORE OF THAT IN THE
YEARS TO COME. YEAH, I DON'T
DISAGREE. I MEAN, I THINK
THAT THAT WAS DEFINITELY I
CAN'T DECIDE IF THAT WAS A
LIKE I THINK WE ALL REALLY
ENJOYED IT THAT PEEK INTO
SORT OF INTO THOSE WORLDS ARE
RIGHT. WE LIKE YOU JUST CAN'T
FOR INSTANCE HAS ALWAYS HAD
LIKE LIVING ROOM CAMS LAST
YEAR. IT WAS JUST IT FELT
MUCH MORE INTIMATE BECAUSE
THERE WAS SO IT WAS LITERALLY
AND SEEING THE GM'S IN THEIR
HOUSES AND KLIFF KINGSBURY. I
MEAN THERE WERE SO MANY GREAT
MOMENTS. I DON'T KNOW IF THAT
WAS SORT OF A FLASH IN THE
PAN LIKE IT WAS KIND OF A FUN
TREND AND I WILL GET BACK TO
NORMAL. I DON'T KNOW BUT BY
THE WAY TO YOUR POINT ONE OF
THE THINGS I THINK THE NFL
HAS DONE WELL AND WHEREVER
YOU STAND ON IT IN TERMS OF
WEATHER SPORTS, YOU KNOW,
LIKE WHAT WHAT HAS HAPPENED
SO FAR. I THOUGHT THAT THEY
ALWAYS AT LEAST CREATED A
PLAN. THEY HAD A PLAN IN
PLACE SO THAT IF THEY GOT TO
THAT POINT
LIKE THE WORST THING IN THE
WORLD IS TO NOT HAVE A PLAN
THEN GET THERE AND BE LIKE
WOW, THERE'S A REALLY GOOD
PORTION OF OUR POPULATION IS
VACCINATED WE COULD HAVE
THESE VACCINATED PEOPLE BE AT
THE DRAFT AND FEEL PRETTY
SAFE ABOUT IT. NOW. I'M NOT
TRYING TO SIT HERE AND SAY
THAT WILL BE THE CASE. BUT IF
THAT TURNS OUT TO BE THE CASE,
AT LEAST YOU HAVE PUT THE
WHEELS IN MOTION TO WHERE YOU
CAN PULL IT OFF. YEAH GET
OUTSIDE. I JUST I DON'T KNOW.
I I COMMEND THE NFL
ON
I'M CONTINUING TO OPERATE AS
IF THINGS WILL HAPPEN AND
THEN AS YOU DID SCALE BACK TO
MAINTAIN PUBLIC SAFETY AND I
THINK LOOK I MEAN WAS THIS
HUGE AMOUNT OF SUCCESS
UNBELIEVER GUARD? I THINK IT
WAS PRETTY UNBELIEVABLE. IT
IS JEFF DARLINGTON EVERYBODY
FROM ESPN NFL REPORTED JEFF.
THANKS FOR TAKING THE TIME
WITH MEDIGAP YOU BET